it became a joke and that's tough to
overcome marketing wise it's tough to
get people to order a but light publicly
now they know the joke you're going to
get made fun of it'll be forgotten in a
month no NOS it's going be while a year
no one will remember it really it you'll
make a joke on stage and be like what no
no no no you guys are C to Bear dude you
guys are crazy it's going to hang in
there for a long time this is going to
be one of them cultural things it's
there's never been a brand that got hit
like this before they'll be back this is
a big deal they'll be saved this month
every single company on Earth is going
to do a gay commercial all of first off
I don't think there should be a month
for any of these things I don't think
there should be a month for Gay Pride I
don't think there should be a black
pride month or a Jewish pride month or a
white pride month or any of these things
you want a day a day is fine a month is
just patently ridiculous